[Musique]
le soleil se lève sur un doux matin de
juin 1279 avant jésus-christ aujourd'hui
on couronne un jeune et dynamique prince
de 25 ans le pharaon ramsès ii cette
journée de cérémonie marque le début
d'une épopée extraordinaire dans
l'histoire de l'egypte antique tout ce
que ramsès ii accomplira au cours de son
règne de 60 et quelques années se fera à
grande échelle
aucun autre pharaons n'engendrera autant
d'enfants ne construira autant de
temples et de monuments
son règne et si édifiant que ses
descendants souverain le surnomme le
grand ancêtre
[Musique]
l'histoire elle-même s'en souvient comme
de l'éminent pharaons
[Musique]
e
lorsque ramsès 2 monte sur le trône
il est prêt à assumer ses fonctions
comme aucun d'entre eux prince ne l'a
été avant lui son père seti premier
s'est illustré par ses exploits
militaires et par une ouverture sans
précédent de son pays aux arts et à l'
architecture
[Musique]
sethi 1er est bien décidé à ce que son
fils une fois pharaons perpétue cet élan
il décide donc pour lui d'une éducation
et d'une instruction militaire des plus
solides
tout jeune le prince ramsès suis déjà
son père dans ses campagnes militaires
en libye et en syrie
et puisque la dynastie repose dorénavant
sur ses épaules en lui inculquant même
temps le devoir d'engendrer une
descendance consistante
[Musique]
ramsès qui se passionne pour le métier
de roi semble avoir parfaitement compris
la leçon
ainsi avant même qu'ils soient couronnés
pharao ces deux femmes principales aux
arrêts mme royal lui aurait déjà donné
plus de 20 enfants
[Musique]
les égyptiens se marier jeune il est
même probable qu'on marié les jeunes
princes dès que possible de sorte qu'ils
commencent à procréer sans perdre de
temps
le principe étant de s'assurer un
maximum de légataire masculin pour le
cas où le premier d'entre eux viendrait
à mourir avant la succession
la deuxième raison de cette précocité
était que la maison royale se devait de
véhiculer auprès du peuple égyptien
une image forte de fécondité ramsès nous
relate lui même sa jeunesse sur les
inscriptions murales au temple de son
père à abidos
cette é tout puissant ma couronne et de
ses mains alors que j'étais enfant il
m'a doté de femmes d'un harem tout
entier et a placé sous mon joue les
peuples du nord et du sud
[Musique]
fort de son expérience sur les grands
chantiers de son père dans l'encadrement
des tailleurs de pierre à la carrière da
souvent ramsès une fois devenu pharaons
s'empresse de faire élever ses propres
monument
[Musique]
ramsès 2 est probablement le premier
grande entrepreneur en bâtiment du monde
c'est certainement le monarque qui a le
plus construit dans l'histoire antique
il est le principal responsable de
l'extension du temple du dieu amon à
louxor au sud du pays
[Musique]
deux mois après son couronnement on y
organise une fête en son honneur pour
marquer en retour sa gratitude
ramsès commandites à louxor une nouvelle
entrée ainsi que deux obélisques dont
celui de la place de la concorde à paris
est la première d'une série de statues
colossales à son effigie voici la partie
supérieure d'une énorme statue à son
image provenant d'un temple qui l'a fait
ben hatira évidence à elle est une
représentation typique des pharaons sous
l'ancienne égypte c'est à dire d'un
adulte viril puissant
cette statue est resté longtemps se vit
sous les sables ce qui lui a permis de
bien se conserver
vous voyez avec quelle vivacité on les
paie niet à l'époque il s'agissait avant
tout de les faire apparaître comme des
entités vivantes
ramsès deux faits et andré embellir la
fameuse salle hypostyle du temple de
karnak débuté sous un mine office 3
[Musique]
avec ses 130 quatre colonnes culminant
autrefois à 23 m cette merveille de
l'architecturé ancienne forme une
véritable forêt de pierres
[Musique]
mais ces grands projets de construction
ne s'en tiennent pas à karnak à louxor
construite tout deux sur les ruines de
thèbes sur la rive est du nil
conformément aux préceptes de religieux
égyptien ramsès fait bâtir son propre
temple funéraire sur la rive ouest du
côté où le soleil se couche
[Musique]
l'édification de cette gigantesque des
crocs paul du nom de ram et siame
requiert alors l'intervention de 3000
tailleur de pierre
bien qu'elle soit aujourd'hui
pratiquement en ruines l'historien grec
diodore de sicile
la dcri à la fin du premier siècle avant
jésus-christ comme surpassant de loin
toutes les autres réalisations de
l'époque
[Musique]
deux statues de granit de 18 mètres de
haut se dressait autrefois ici en
protectrice des lieux il ne subsiste
aujourd'hui que le buste de l'une
d'entre elles
[Musique]
il faut cependant descendre plus au sud
à la frontière actuelle avec le soudan
pour trouver le plus magistral de ses
monuments
le temple d'abou simbel
[Musique]
creusée à même une falaises de grès rose
il domine la vallée sa grandeur semble
vouloir rappeler à quiconque navigue là
sur les eaux du nil qu'ils entrent dans
le pays des dieux
on estime que la construction d'abou
simbel débute dans la dixième année du
règne de ramsès ii en 1269 avant
jésus-christ et qu'elle dure 13 ans
[Musique]
bien qu'il soit dédié au dieu amon rê et
à ce gigantesque monument divinise avant
tout le dieu et roy ramsès en personne
[Musique]
d'une façade qu'on dirait presque surgi
de terre quatre portraits colossaux du
pharaon domine la vallée de leur toute
puissance
si ces géants de 20 mètres pouvait se
lever il en attendre est pratiquement 30
[Musique]
les représentations de l'entourage de
ramsès 2 cette divinité femmes enfants
et amis restent en comparaison du nu
skull
le temple d'abou simbel est en soi un
modèle de technique architecturale son
orientation a été calculé de telle sorte
que deux jours par an seulement aux
équinoxes de printemps et d'automne les
rayons du soleil levant traverse
l'entrée et inonde de lumière les
statues du roi représenté sous les
traits du dieu osiris
ils poursuivent ensuite le long d'un
corridor de 65 m pour pénétrer la partie
la plus secrète du sanctuaire et
illuminait les statuts de 3 dieu parmi
lesquels ramsès
[Musique]
un quatrième dieu me tah n'apparaît que
partiellement à la lumière du jour
tu as est en effet la divinité des
ombres
[Musique]
et
plus petit le second temple d'abou
simbel et dédié à la reine néfertari
épouse favorite de ramsès ii
d'un simple présence des six statues du
couple sur sa façade révèle tout l'amour
que le roi éprouve pour elle
être associé à ce point au pharaon lui
même est en effet un immense privilège
il est d'ailleurs probable que la reine
néfertari est assisté à l'inauguration
de sont angles
[Musique]
lorsque des faits rares y meurt en 1254
avant jésus-christ ramsès ii a déjà fait
bâtir à son attention une tombe dans la
vallée des reines sur la rive ouest du
nil près de thèbes
[Musique]
s'enfonçant à près de huit mètres sous
terre
c'est aussi culture récemment restaurée
est ouverte au public
reste à ce jour l'un des plus beaux
exemples de tombes royales sous
l'ancienne egypte
[Musique]
les fresques du caveau montre néfertari
dans des poses symbolique en compagnie
des dieux
à peu près à la même époque que
l'édification d' abou simbel
ramsès ii entreprend au nord-est du
delta du nil la construction de son père
rahme sous ou domaine de ramsès celui ci
jouera bientôt dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
un rôle très important
depuis 400 ans en effet le peuple hébreu
vit paisiblement dans le delta du nil on
pense que ramsès 2 préoccupé comme son
père avant lui par leur grand nombre
aurait choisi de les forcer aux travaux
et un temps pour la construction de sa
ville on pense que c'est ici qu'a débuté
vers 1263 avant jésus-christ l'exode
tels que la bible nous là relate quand
on parle de ramsès 2 on pense souvent à
la période de l'exode les détails sur
l'egypte figurant au livre de l'exode
dans la bible concordent avec ceux qui
illustrent le règne de ramsès ii et son
royaume de ram et sous je dirais que cet
épisode a vraiment eu lieu
et si ça la bible en témoigne c'est
parce que l'événement tout relatif qu'il
était pour les égyptiens de l'époque
allait demeurer comme capital dans
l'histoire des juifs 1
[Musique]
qu'il ait été ou non le grand pharaon
mentionné par la bible il est clair que
ramsès ii est alors déterminé à laisser
aux quatre coins de l'empiré son
empreinte toute puissante
en faisant élevé autant de monuments à
sa gloire il se hisse à l'image d'un
dieu
[Musique]
à
sa gloire cependant ne s'appuie pas
uniquement sur ses réalisations
architecturales mais aussi sur sa
capacité à écraser l'ennemi
[Musique]
si un seul pharaons devait subsister
parmi ceux ayant marqué la longue
civilisation de l'ancienne egypte c'est
bien lui
ramsès ii et le plus prolifique à tous
points de vue y compris sur les champs
de bataille
[Musique]
au cours de ces soixante sept années de
règne ses conquêtes à l'étranger y nom
de l'egypte de richesses en même temps
qu'elles encouragent une véritable
explosion culturel les impôts qu'il lève
ainsi que c'est butin de guerre lui
permettent de financer l'embellissement
des temples et la construction de
nouveaux monuments ses esclaves faits
prisonniers au cours des nombreuses
batailles lui garantissent la main
d'oeuvre nécessaire
[Musique]
au nord-est de l'ancien régime c'est en
un vaste désert marquée aujourd'hui par
la syrie
[Musique]
si ces types remis à garder le contrôle
des régions côtières sud le peuple des
hittites tient encore sous sa domination
la ville stratégique de kamdesh dans une
région que ramsès ii reste déterminé à
reprendre un jour ou l'autre
[Musique]
dans la quatrième année de son règne
profitant d'une révolte dans les
territoires occupés il décide de sceller
à jamais l'oeuvre expansionniste de son
père en chassant une bonne fois pour
toutes les demies hittites de ses
bastions
[Musique]
au i parvenir il lui faudra affronter sa
plus dure épreuve
la bataille de kamdesh
[Musique]
des inscriptions nous raconte ainsi qu
en 1275 avant jésus-christ il rassemble
l'une des plus vastes armée que l'egypte
est alors connu
vingt mille hommes traversent la bande
de gaza et font route vers kadesh
[Musique]
alors qu'ils parviennent presque à
destination la capture et
l'interrogatoire de deux espions
hittites leur fait croire à tort que
l'ennemi terrorisé s'est déplacé à 160
km au nord confiant à ramsès poursuit le
chemin avec seulement un quart de ses
troupes et établit son campement sans
savoir qu'une formidable embuscade les
attend lorsqu'il réalise le traquenard
il est déjà trop tard
miraculeusement il parvient avec ses
hommes à tenir en haleine l'ennemi it it
jusqu'à l'arrivée des renforts égyptien
s'il évite de justesse la débâcle de
nombreuses égyptologue estime que la
bataille de kadesh finira en impasse
un avis que le pharaon à l'époque semble
loin de partager
[Musique]
les murs des temples de karnak et louxor
david hauss dabou sa belle et du ram et
ses hommes décrits faut au contraire les
triomphes de ramsey sa cadette
[Musique]
ces fameuses victoire militaire que l'on
célèbre ici comme les plus grandioses de
l'ancienne egypte ont elles donc
réellement eu lieu la représentation et
la description de la bataille de kadesh
figure parmi les documents historiques
les plus intéressants dont nous
disposons sur le règne de ramsès 2 on y
dépeint le pharaon comme le vainqueur
magistral des hittites alors qu'en
réalité
même s'il n'a pas été contraints de
battre en retraite
ramsay s'est retrouvé dans l'impasse
sans aucun espoir immédiat de
reconquérir la syrie
d'autres échecs militaires suivront
avant que ramsès ne réalise qu'il vaut
mieux tirer un trait sur la syrie
là où certains voient le premier traité
de paix de l'histoire les deux pays
signent en 1259 avant jésus-christ
impact mutuelle de non-agression gravé
dans des plaques de pierre et d'argile
les deux versions du document hittites
égyptiens ont survécu jusqu'à nous
[Musique]
une fois la paire amené ramsès ii aurait
épousé une princesse it it afin de
sceller davantage le traité son harem se
serait même agrémenté de femmes
syriennes et babylonienne
[Musique]
ramsès ii meurt en 1212 avant
jésus-christ à l'âge de 92 ans
après l'avoir momifié en enveloppes sa
dépouille dans un linceul doré avant de
la placer dans un sarcophage de pierre
que l'on ensevelis près de ses ancêtres
dans la vallée lee roy
[Musique]
malgré toutes les précautions prises
pour assurer aux pharaons sa vie
éternelle dans l'au delà
sa tombe est régulièrement pillés au
cours des deux siècles qui suivent
après l'avoir enveloppes et des prêtres
se chargent de déplacés d'urgence sa
momie les restes de ramsès deux
finissent dans un simple cercueil de
bois de cerf
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'en 1882 notre ère que l'on
retrouve cette momie parmi leurs autres
dans la cache royal de deir el bahari
creusé près du temple de la reine
hatchepsout
[Musique]
l'analyse de sa mamie révélera notamment
que ramsès d'eux portait les cheveux
roux et qu'il mesurait environ un mètre
soixante dix obturés par des grains de
poivre au cours de l'embaumement son nez
aquilin c'est bien conservé
l'impossibilité du pharaon de trouver le
repos après la mort est révélatrice du
sort de l'egypte le pays amorce à cette
époque un long et difficile déclin
[Musique]
qu'on pense que ramsès ii a engendré
plus de 200 enfants dont 100 au moins
ont atteint l'âge adulte ces douze
premiers fils héritier dans leur
chronologie décèdent avant leur père
c'est le treizième du nom de merenda qui
assurent la relève à l'âge de 60 ans
[Musique]
et bien qu'ils se démarquent par deux
victorieuses campagne militaire contre
les libyens et les syriens son règne
long de dix ans seulement ne lui permet
pas d'égaliser les réalisations de son
père
[Musique]
la découverte d'une partie du palais de
mérenptah à memphis reste pourtant un
moment important dans l'histoire de
l'archéologie
c'est la toute première fois qu'on met
au jour les vestiges d'une ancienne
résidence royale égyptienne des
fragments de ce complexe architectural
ainsi qu'une maquette du palais exposé
aux états unis au musée archéologique de
l'université de pennsylvanie permettent
de mesurer toute la grâce des intérieurs
qui font alors le quotidien des pharaons
[Musique]
ses sculptures et gravures provenant de
son palais il représente le pharaon dans
une pose propre à son rang sur ce
fragment mérenptah se tient face au dieu
créateur at on que vous voyez à droite
at on lui remet le fléau et la houlette
symbole de la royauté mérenptah apparaît
ici coiffé de la couronne et yann
oiseaux échassiers qu'on appelle un van
os et qui symbolise le peuple égyptien
des hiéroglyphes à l'entrée du palais
met en exergue les liens qui l'attachent
en tant que pharaon aux puissances
divines
[Musique]
le déchiffrage donne ceci entre
remettant le fléau et la houlette je
t'ordonne pharaons pour des millions
d'années on a là un concentré de
l'interaction qui existe entre le roi et
les dieux égyptiens où l'on voit
clairement la façon dont il me confère
les pleins pouvoirs
si à la mort de merenda en 1202 avant
jésus-christ la glorieuse 19ème dynastie
n'est déjà plus qu'une vieille histoire
l'épopée des grands pharaons ne s'achève
pas la peau autant
ramsès iii lui succède en digne
représentant d'une puissante egypte
alors qu'une reine du nom de cléopâtre
s'apprête à devenir l'héroïne d'un drame
qui passionnera le monde entier
[Musique]
sous les contreforts des montagnes
protégeant la vallée des rois se cachent
sur le site de médecine est à vous le
temple funéraire le mieux préservé de
toute l'ancienne ville de thèbes
c'est aussi outre le seul temple
d'égypte à avoir fait l'objet d'un
relevé architectural détail et celui
dont on a des chiffres et l'intégralité
des reliefs et hiéroglyphes ramsès iii
second pharaon de la 20e dynastie en est
le commanditaire il ne descend pas de la
même lignée que celle de l'éminent
ramsès ii dont il n'a de commun que le
nom
[Musique]
lorsqu'il monte sur le trône en 1182
avant jésus-christ ramsès iii hérite
d'une égypte stable et d'une nation
relativement tranquille mais huit ans
plus tard il se voit contraint
d'affronter un ennemi redoutable les
peuples de la mer
[Musique]
vers 1176 avant jésus-christ les
anciennes nations situées à l'est de la
méditerranée sur les territoires actuels
de la turquie de la syrie et d'israël se
retrouvent prises sous la menace armée
d'envahisseurs connu sous le nom
générique de peuples de la mer
[Musique]
le temple funéraire de ramsès iii à
médine est tabou nous livre le long
récit de l'invasion puis du rejet
d'égypte des peuples de la mer une
invasion qui fut maritime mais également
terrestre
car s'ils sont bien accompagné de
farouches guerriers ces peuples de la
mer sont avant tout des hommes des
femmes et des enfants à la recherche du
notaire ou s'établir la menace pour
l'egypte semble alors d'autant plus
grave que ces peuplades sont parvenues à
écraser les hittites les grands rivaux
des égyptiens
ramsès iii ordonne donc d'urgence à ces
avant postes militaires de défendre
coûte que coûte les frontières de
lempire le temps qu'il envoie sur place
son armée repousser l'envahisseur
la première des deux grandes batailles a
lieu près de la frontière syrienne
si ramsès iii en sort vainqueur
il doit encore affronter la formidable
puissance maritime des peuples de la mer
les peintures murales des temples de
ramsès montre les archers du pharaon
tirant sans relâche leurs flèches sur
les lignes ennemies ce fut un team de
guern tout à fait inhabituel pour les
égyptiens il s'agissait de se poser un
peuple exotiques dont il ne connaissait
pas le moins du monde le potentiel
militaire et stratégique
une victoire pourtant éphémère puisque
trois ans plus tard ramsès iii doit
repousser une nouvelle invasion l'ennemi
qui attaquent cette fois la frontière
ouest de l'egypte est une alliance de
plusieurs tribus dont celle des libyens
[Musique]
après un nouveau triomphe militaire les
scribes se mettent à recenser les pertes
du camp ennemi
on coupe la main droite des cadavres que
l'on apporte aux pharaons avant de les
compter ramsès ordonne un jour que l'on
recommence le dénombrement cette fois en
lui présentant le phallus de ses
victimes
[Musique]
ramsès iii vient à nouveau de sauver sa
nation et l'ironie du sort veut que l'on
s'en prenne à sa vie
[Musique]
l'histoire nous a légué le compte rendu
de l' enquête officielle qui a suivi
l'attentât
mais ce rapport ne dit pas clairement si
ramsès a échappé à une tentative ou bien
s'il a réellement été assassiné on sait
que l'instigatrice du complot est une
reine secondaire du nom de ti
elle aurait pu agir par déception que
son fils ne figure qu'en position
éloignée dans la liste des prétendants
au trône
alors j'ai cherché à éliminer ramsès
afin d'usurper la lignée royale au
profit de sa propre descendance et
prendre ainsi le contrôle de l'egypte
l'un des conspirateurs auraient d'autre
part rompu le secret
[Musique]
le procès impliquera plus de 40 conjurer
après avoir été reconnu coupable
six d'entre eux se suicident face aux
jurés évitant ainsi une mort lente et
épouvantable par amp allemand
[Musique]
d'autres reconnu coupable à un degré
moindre de participation ont les
oreilles et le nez tranchés que cette
tentative d'assassinât était ou non
couronnée de succès il est clair que
ramsès iii est mort avant le rendu des
verdicts
cette fin de règne déplorable présage
des troubles qui agitent seront bientôt
l'egypte après 1 6 3 une période de
scission politique et de tension sociale
s'installe peu à peu les successeurs ont
l'air de maîtriser beaucoup moins bien
la situation et le pays commence à se
partager entre plusieurs royaume
gouverné par plusieurs pharaons
certains géologues tente une explication
l'egypte ne se limite plus à l'étroit
paisible vallée du nil d'autres grands
empires surgissent tout autour notamment
la syrie on est là dans une époque de
fluctuation déstabilise l'egypte et la
font chuter de son piédestal et le pays
souffre tout entier de cela
sur les huit siècles qui suivent près de
70 souverains issus de onze nouvelles
dynasties se succèdent au trône d'égypte
parmi eux figurent des conquérants
libyen nubien syrien et perth
en 333 jésus-christ le pays alors sous
la domination des perses doit affronter
l'un des plus grands chefs militaires de
tous les temps alexandre le grand
[Musique]
fils du roi philippe ii de macédoine
alexandre le grand incarne dans la
graisse de l'époque le pouvoir dominant
[Musique]
après avoir reçu son éducation du
philosophe aristote le jeune alexandre
accède au trône en 336 avant
jésus-christ après que son père ait été
assassiné il veut avant tout vaincre les
perses qui menace la grèce depuis plus
de 200 ans
[Musique]
à 25 ans ces succès rapide lui
permettent de libérer les cités grecques
et de triompher du grand roi des perses
dariaus à la bataille du granik en juin
334 avant jésus-christ
peu après avoir goûté l'ennemi hors de
grèce il pénètre en egypte en libérateur
on le couronne même pharaon et on
l'élève au statut de dieu
[Musique]
alexandre était à noël ou doué d'une
intelligence remarquable
il a su faire preuve en egypte plus que
partout ailleurs de sa perspicacité et
de son flair en matière de politique
et même si ces armes et ne le
considérait pas comme un dieu vivant
il avait compris comme ses conseillers
qu'en se rendant maîtres de l'egypte il
lui faudrait là bas endosser la cape
royal et être adoré comme une divinité
mais malgré ce nouveau titre de pharaon
son destin le conduit ailleurs
peu après avoir fondé la ville
d'alexandrie dont il fait la nouvelle
capitale du royaume
il repart en conquête sur des terres qui
le mène jusqu en inde
[Musique]
cependant et alors qu'il a toujours su
remonter ses nombreuses blessures de
guerre une fièvre l'emportent en 323
avant jésus-christ dans la ville de
babylone
ces généraux décide de se partager son
vaste empire parmi eux son officier et
ami d'enfance tollé mais sa
revendication du royaume marque le début
de la dernière dynastie égyptienne une
dynastie qui en même temps qu'elle fait
du pays un riche foyer culturel et
artistique bâtir à l'une des sept
merveilles du monde et verra l'avènement
d'une des reines les plus célèbres de
l'histoire
[Musique]
dans les fonds marins au large du port
d'alexandrie repose la clé d'une énigme
vieille de plus de deux mille ans
les souverains se promenait autrefois
sur cette chaussée qui reliait la ville
à la petite île de pharos
détruit par une succession de
tremblement de terre à partir du 4e
siècle ce n'est qu'il y a quelques
années qu'on relève dans ces parages les
vestiges significative du grand phare
d'alexandrie et du palais de cleo pas
[Musique]
chapitre de notre épopée des plus grands
pharaons débutants 323 avant
jésus-christ lorsque pauline et premier
général macédoniens et fidèle lieutenant
d'alexandre le grand
revendiquent le trône d'égypte avant de
se proclamer lui même pharaon il devient
en 305 avant jésus-christ le premier roi
de la 32ème dynastie celle des ptolémées
[Musique]
la dynastie égyptienne des ptolémées
s'est illustré par son maintien la
plupart du temps d'un pays stable et
prospère
elle a su rester respectueuse des
traditions religieuses locales tout en
continuant de pratiquer sa religion
grecque
la succession des ptolémées apparaît
d'ailleurs en peinture sur les murs de
nombreux temples comme la dernière est
prestigieuse dynastie de la royauté
égyptienne
les ptolémées sont eux aussi de grands
bâtisseurs parmi leurs oeuvres majeures
la monumentale bibliothèque d'alexandrie
[Musique]
ces murs abrité autrefois quelques 700
muhlmann us plus sévères ce haut lieu de
la culture scientifique et littéraire
caf lui alors des quatre coins du monde
savant et autres érudits en quête de
connaissances les ptolémées dresse
également le grand phare d'alexandrie
réplique gigantesque d'un premier
exemplaire dont ils sont aussi les
auteurs on le surnomme la septième et
dernière merveille de l'ancien monde
[Musique]
culminant à 135 mètres depuis la petite
île de pharos face au port d'alexandrie
sont fans à l'alimenter par un immense
brasier est alors visibles à plus de 160
kilomètres à la ronde
[Musique]
malgré ces glorieuses illustrations et
peu à peu miné par les rivalités
familiales le déclin économique
les dissensions politiques et la
puissance croissante de rome cette
dynastie d'une quinzaine de roy fini par
s'éteindre
au milieu du 1er siècle avant
jésus-christ alors que jules césar
rayonne jusque sur les eaux du nil les
ptolémées ne sont plus que des
souverains fantoche en 51 avant
jésus-christ dans l'est mais douze
langues le trône d'égypte à sa fille de
18 ans cléopâtre la septième du nom
celle ci est contrainte de partager ses
responsabilités avec son frère de 10 ans
de les maîtresses
né en 69 avant jésus-christ cléopâtre
manie couramment cette langue
elle est la seule des pharaons grec à
savoir par les égyptiens
contrairement à la légende elle
n'incarne pas la beauté suprême
c'est pourtant une femme sensuelle doué
d'une voix voluptueuse et d'une
intelligence exceptionnelle
[Musique]
le grand philosophe plus tard qui écrira
d'elle
le timbre de sa voix était tout
simplement un régal pour les oreilles à
la manière d'un musicien jouant sur
plusieurs cordes
elle savait passer d'une langue à
l'autre au point qu'elle avait rarement
besoin d'un interprète
pillot battre devra user de tous ses
talents pour garder le contrôle d'une
égypte qu'elle aime énormément
peu après sa montée sur le trône
ces dissensions avec son frère s'achève
en une guerre civile pur et dur au cours
de laquelle certains égyptologues pense
que la grande bibliothèque d'alexandrie
auraient été détruites
forcé de fuir provisoirement vers la
syrie cléopâtre revient à alexandrie
lorsqu'elle apprend que jules césar
vient d'y entrer
[Musique]
elle a réalisé qu'avec la puissance
croissante de rome dans le monde
méditerranéen
elle avait très peu d'espoir de se
maintenir reine d'égypte et lorsque
césar est entré en egypte
elle s'est mise en tête de le séduire
comme on a tous pu le voir dans bon
nombre de scénarii de pièces et de films
ses servantes la dissimule dans un tapis
et l'apasp l'investissement jusqu'au
quartier de jules césar à alexandrie
lorsqu'il déroule ce tapis qu'on lui
présente comme un cadeau l'empereur
découvre avec enchantement la reine
d'égypte qui devine à ce moment là
qu'elle vient de gagner son meilleur ami
vaincu son frère ptolémée xiii se noie
mystérieusement
[Musique]
quelques semaines plus tard césar s'en
retourne à rome laissant cléopâtre
enceinte de leur fils scénario
un an passent avant qu'il ne lui demande
de le rejoindre
mais sa présence à rome est vécu comme
un outrage venant s'ajouter aux
querelles de l'empereur avec le sénat
cet affront conduit à l'assassinât de
césar en 44 avant jésus-christ
[Musique]
léopard rentre alors en egypte l'arrière
petit neveu de césar octavien ainsi que
l'un de ses anciens conseillers marc
antoine décide de combler le vide
politique laissé par sa disparition
[Musique]
mais leur partage du pouvoir s'avère
bientôt impossible et marc antoine se
tourner vers cléopâtre pour lui réclamer
son assistance antoine est ébloui par le
charme de cette femme dont il découvre
en même temps les ans dans des sujets de
conversation a priori réservé aux hommes
d'état
[Musique]
c'est le début d'une histoire d'amour
doublée d'une solide alliance politique
où ils jouent tous deux à la fois leur
destin et celui de l'egypte
[Musique]
après une ultime et infructueuse
tentative d'arrondir les angles avec
octavien antoine décide de rejoindre une
bonne fois pour toutes cléopâtre
[Musique]
pu être ses motivations amoureuse
ils attendaient aussi de cléopâtre de
l'argent et du bois pour construire ces
bateaux pendant qu'elle de son côté
voulait de nouvelles concessions de
terres ainsi que davantage de garanties
fiscale il était par conséquent tout
autant amoureux qu associer
ainsi marc antoine lui fait-il cadeaux
comme alors deux enfants de conquête
romaine en asie il reconnaît en outre et
proclame que césarion le fils qu'elle a
eu avec jules césar et bien le
successeur légitime
[Musique]
on a là une situation dans laquelle un
grand et noble général romain offre
délibérément des morceaux de lempiras
une reine étrangères vous imaginez
l'indignation des sénateurs romains et
c'est comme ça que marc antoine est
devenu l'ennemi public numéro un
octavien exploite alors l'indignation
que suscite ces abandons de territoire
pour remporter le soutien de l'armée et
déclaré la guerre au couple maudit
en 31 avant jésus-christ octavien et
c'est romain enserre la flotte
égyptienne dans la bataille navale
d'actu
face à une défaite inéluctable antoine
et cléopâtre prennent la fuite
[Musique]
en moins d'un an les romains sont par
d'alexandrie et les forces égyptiennes
capitule
bancal marc-antoine savez le destin
qu'on lui réservait et il a choisi une
sortie de scène à la romaine
il s'est suicidé avec son épée dans
alexandrie a siégé cléopâtre elle
s'attendait à ce qu'on leur chaîne par
les poignets et les chevilles pour
l'exhiber dans une rome triomphante
il n'était pas question donc plus qu
elle tente de séduire octavien après
césar puis antoine qu'elle aimait et
venait de perdre
octavien qui en tout cas s'assurer par
cet immense victoire
la domination du monde romain marc
antoine aurait expiré entre les bras de
cléopâtre la reine elle même prête à se
donner la mort ordonne alors qu'on lui
apporte en secret un serpent venimeux
[Musique]
à 39 ans entourée de ses domestiques
elle succombe à la morsure de l'animal
[Musique]
il ne faut pas croire que ce fut
forcément pour elle la pierre des morts
ce type de peine capitale était assez
répandu en egypte à l'époque et l'on
peut s'attendre à ce que cléopâtre se
soit fait à l'idée de mourir de cette
manière
avec le dernier souffle de cléopâtre
s'achève la grande épopée des pharaons
une dîme fin en soi pour l'une des plus
grandes histoires d'amour de tous les
temps et pour la civilisation de
l'ancienne egypte qui aura duré plus
longtemps que tout autre
[Musique]
si les suzerains égyptien et romain
s'attache ensuite à perpétuer les
traditions en continuant notamment
d'endosser le titre de pharaon et de
construire des temples alors dieu c'est
uniquement dans le but de garder le
contrôle de la population
l'egypte a d'ores et déjà changé de
visage elle n'est plus qu'un immense
réservoir destiné à alimenter en
richesse lempire de rome
[Musique]
laissé à l'abandon les magnifiques lieux
saints et monuments édifiés sur plus de
trois millénaires décrépissent lentement
mais sûrement
tout ce qui n'a pas encore été dégradées
ou pillées devient la proie du sable et
des ventes et couleurs vives s'efface
peu à peu alors qu'un patrimoine entier
de majestueuses et gracile silhouette
s'enfonce sous la surface anonyme du
désert
les voix de ces pharaons mi homme mi
dieu se sont tues à jamais emportant
dans leur silence la magnificence de la
civilisation du grand empire du nil
mais l'héritage principal des plus
grands pharaons d'égypte a malgré tout
survécu à l'oublier aux destructions
[Musique]
défiant les millénaires ces visages
fascinant témoigne de la gloire
éternelle de la nature humaine et révèle
combien ces anciens géants nous sont
restés proches
[Musique]